i'm trying something new with this
caption contest namely using an image
that somebody
gave me it's quite a funny meme rather
than
just using an image as i've done in the
past of myself
doing something or with one of my pets
and it turned out pretty good i got a
number
of responses i'm putting the top 10 here
for you
so you can enjoy them maybe have your
thought provoked by them or at least
laugh
at them so with no further ado
all of you know who these figures are
i'm assuming right ernie and burt from
sesame street if you don't know them
then you probably want to look them up
but in any case what we see is ernie and
burt
with hegel's phenomenology of spirit so
again with no further ado i'm going to
jump right in
to the captions so this first one
uses muppet as a derogatory
term of abuse and it actually references
rene descartes i think most of you know
kojito
is found in a couple places in his works
and it's
associated with him and so one of them
maybe ernie is saying wrong book you
muppet
meaning that it's uh you know the wrong
thing to bring up i mean what would be
the catchphrase for hegel the real is
rational and the rational is real
perhaps
so i guess everybody has catchphrases if
we dig
deep enough here's the second one and
this is a
quite clever one right it says pictured
in the form of
muppets fairness terrying with the burt
griff
right and so the references there are of
course to
hegel fernand is reason
and the grief is concept or
notion and these are very important
terms for hegel and for german idealism
generally so he managed or
whoever it is is managed to get ernie
in there and burt in there with the
parentheses and it actually
kind of works so again very clever
here's another one and here this is the
first of uh
two that that have to do with on sesame
street there's usually a letter of the
day a number of the day and apparently
also
shapes of the day it's been a long time
since i've watched the show
so w is for veldtgeist bart
right bert's rather and and so you know
w could be for all sorts of things and
in this case it's for world spirit which
is another key
idea in hegel's thought and works
so good one there here's another one
brought to you to by today's shape the
triadic
schema a lot of people associate hegel
unfortunately because it's a mistake
with this triadic schema
which they associate with hegelian
dialectic and if you can't see i'm
putting that in
air quotes as i'm saying it because it's
not actually hegelian
and it's not the way he figures the
dialectic where you have thesis
antithesis synthesis and it's
represented with a triangle
it's actually kind of a fractal in some
ways because
it's unfolded into the next one of
course this is not what hegel actually
taught
it's coming from ficta but you know
that's the popular way of
talking about hegel today so that's
that's a good joke right there
now we get somewhere ernie and bird are
talking to each other
ernie says you can't just read the
preface
over and over bert you have to read the
whole thing and
you know i suppose there may be some
people out there who
do that with with works hegel's preface
would somewhat resist that but i'm
willing to bet there's at least one
person out there
like that um here's another one based on
my eyeball estimate bird has just
reached the lordship and bondage section
of the phenomenology of spirit
it's probably the only section most
people actually
read of the phenomenology it's a very
short section and not
really that characteristic of the entire
work but it's it's the sexy section
that everybody likes to reference and so
good joke
there as well and here's one in german
albert and ernst lightened
burt and ernie are um
you know bringing to bringing the the
system to
an end the system of the absolute or
working their way through it
and achieving a
fraternal i guess we could say unity
okay not bad you know again though
as the two previous people have pointed
out
it doesn't look like they're anywhere
near the end of the work so
maybe not who knows uh here's another
one
um after having heard the preface
did the most beautiful expressions of
pure thought flowing from the
enlightened spirit of
ernie bert realized this wasn't such an
appropriate
bedtime story so apparently bert is
reading this to ernie
in this scenario and ernie is somehow
responding
um i'm not sure if bert does read ernie
bedtime stories they're they're both
adults right and they live together but
maybe ernie
who's a little bit childlike in some
ways maybe he does get bedtime stories
read to him i i don't know
uh here's another really good one ernie
bert you can't just say
absolute knowing and expect anything to
happen bert
i didn't say it i declared it and this
is actually a really funny one
because you know if you think about
hegel i you know i really like hegel
but the the notion that like history's
all wrapped up and we've reached
absolute knowing
it it is kind of uh you know with the
distance of
200 years a little bit of a a silly
assertion right
and hegel is is sometimes
much less logical and
painstaking as he tries to portray
himself as being
and does declare an awful lot so that's
a good one
finally here's the the one i like the
best
save the best for last and once you've
finished the phenomenology you'll
understand hegel well enough to read
the phenomenology and that is quite true
and so somebody else commented this is
actually true in my experience mine too
um so many people want to like you know
get hegel right the first time around no
it doesn't work that way
you know you you have to make your way
through it
and plow through and not understand what
you're doing
and then you can go back the second time
you've got a way better
idea of what you're doing and this makes
perfect sense because it's the way it is
with with most philosophical works
actually
and it works that way with like
exploring a city and it works that way
with learning a musical composition and
life is like that so this is actually a
great observation to wrap
up with so thanks to everybody who
contributed
i'll do more of these in the future
since people seem to like them
and hope you enjoy it
you